we are polluting dark sir we have lost
engines generate a Mayday Mayday
passionately the moment of disaster the
passenger jet crashed into this
residential area in the port city of
Karachi Tara for those who fell from the
sky and for those who watched from the
ground houses crushed the frame of
Pakistan International Airlines flight
eight three zero three halting in this
alley I saw from the rooftop of my house
lots of smoke in the sky
so I ran towards the scene and saw the
wreckage of the planes cockpit and the
body of a pilot inside many of the 107
passengers and crew are feared dead
casualties among residents as well but
at least two on board survived including
the president to the Pakistani Bank
Zafar Massoud and this man named as
Mohammad Zubair
the air bus ran into trouble on its
approach to Karachi Airport after
leaving the [ __ ] an investigation will
seek to find out why the last message
that we heard from the pilot was that
the plane have developed a technical
problem he was informed that both
runways were ready for the final
approach and he could land on any of
them but the pilot decided that he
wanted to go around acting a problem it
was the aircraft sixth flight since
resuming operations after a coronavirus
lockdown
a devastating blow as this country
prepares for the Eid holiday following
the holy month of Ramadan
Deborah Haynes Sky News